[MUSIC PLAYING]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
How's everyone doing today?
Yeah?
Good.
All right.
Well, welcome to Google I/O. My
name is Eitan Marder-Eppstein.
And I am an engineering
manager here at Google.
And I work on augmented reality.
And I'm going to take a few
polls throughout this talk.
And the first one
is how many of you
are familiar with augmented
reality in general?
OK.
Every time I give a talk
like this, more hands go up,
which is a really,
really great thing.
And today, what
I'm going to do is
give a quick refresher about
augmented reality for those
of you who maybe aren't
quite as familiar with it,
and especially how augmented
reality relates to smartphones,
which is something that
we're really, really
excited about here at Google.
And then I'm going to talk
about some of the things
that we're doing at
Google to improve
our platform for augmented
reality and the capabilities
that we give to some
of these devices.
All right.
So I need my clicker.
So I'm actually going
to go over here to get
the presentation started.
But off we go.
So smartphone AR stems
from this observation
that over the last
decade, our phones
have gotten immensely
more powerful,
CPUs and GPUs have
improved a lot.
But the ability of phones
to see and understand
their environments, and
really make sense of the world
around them, until
very recently was
largely unchanged and limited.
So if you pointed your
phone at this table,
it would allow you to take
a picture of the table
or even a video of your friend
climbing over the table.
But your phone wouldn't
really have an understanding
of the geometry of the
table, of its position
relative to the table as
it moves through space.
And so what augmented reality
seeks to do on smartphones
is to take all of this amazing
advancement in computing power
and leverage it to bring new
capabilities to your phone,
and to take your phone from
beyond just the screen,
beyond its own little box,
to expand it to understanding
the world around it.
So now, when my phone
looks at this table,
it can see that there's
a surface there,
that there are
chairs next to it.
And as I move through
the environment,
my phone can actually track
its position as it moves.
And we think at Google
that augmented reality
is really exciting.
And we've been excited
to see some of the stuff
that you've built. And
we've categorized it
into two main buckets
where we think
augmented reality can be really,
really great for applications.
So the first bucket is we think
that augmented reality can
be useful on smartphones.
So recently, I was
remodeling my kitchen.
All right, another
poll-- how many of you
have remodeled
anything in a house?
All right.
So if you've done that,
you know that measurements
is a real pain.
And what I needed to do was
measure for a backsplash.
We were buying some subway
tile for our kitchen.
And I, instead of taking
a tape measure out,
actually pulled out my
phone, went to my counter,
and measured from point A to
B to C. And I did all of that
without moving any
of my appliances
where I would have normally
had to move in order
to get an accurate measurement
with my tape measure.
So AR can be useful
in that way, just
from providing a better
geometric understanding
about your environment.
AR can also be useful for
shopping applications.
So recently, we had some
very old chairs at my house.
And my partner and I were
looking to replace them,
kind of like these chairs here.
And we were getting
into a debate over which
chairs we liked more.
And so with
augmented reality, we
were able to take a
3D model of a chair,
place it in the environment,
see the exact size and scale
and color.
And we could have our
arguments about inevitably
what kind of chair
we would have at home
rather than exposing
everyone to it at the store,
and be more targeted about
how we made our purchase
and even buy this furniture
online and feel much more
comfortable with it.
So that's how AR can
just provide more utility
in your daily life.
But AR can also be fun.
So imagine a character
running across the floor,
jumping onto this chair,
and jumping onto this table,
or me sitting in
one of these chairs
and having the floor
drop out from under me
to create an ice fishing game.
Ice fishing sounds
a little bit boring,
but I can tell you
that in this game,
it's actually a lot of fun.
And AR can also be used
for creative expression.
So here, now in your pocket,
you have a lot of ability
to go out and create
new things that
were previously only capable
to be created by professionals.
So you can generate
computer-generated content
on the go, on the fly.
You can take your
favorite character
and put them into
your scene, and have
your friend pose next to them.
Or you can take pizza or hot
dogs or your favorite food
items, as we showed
here, and put them
on the table in front of you.
But now, you have this amazing
video editing capability
in your pocket.
And for those of you who
have seen our AR Stickers
application on the
Google Pixel phone,
you know what I'm talking about.
And for those who haven't,
please check it out.
It's really, really cool
to have this creation
power in your pocket.
All right.
So that's great.
AR can be useful.
AR can be fun.
But how do you actually
build applications for AR?
How do you get
involved as developers?
This is a developer conference.
So how many of you are familiar
with ARCore, when I say ARCore?
All right, about half of you.
So ARCore is Google's
development platform
for augmented reality.
We want to make it easy for
you to build applications that
take advantage of
these new capabilities
that phones provide, of
the ability of phones
to see and understand
their environments,
and to build applications
that actually
react to this understanding.
And ARCore was launched
a few months ago.
And it provides three
main capabilities
to allow you to do this.
The first is something
we call motion tracking.
So here, consider the example
of taking the Scarecrow
from "The Wizard
of Oz" and wanting
to place the Scarecrow
at a taco stand
and make it seem like he's
waiting in line for tacos
because everyone loves tacos.
So here, if I look at the
Scarecrow with my phone,
ARCore actually
understands its position
relative to a virtual object
that I've placed in space.
So as I move a meter
forward, the phone
knows that I've moved a
meter in this direction.
And as I turn left, the
phone also knows that.
It's able to track its motion
as I move through space.
And now, if I combine
that with my desire
to place the Scarecrow
a meter in front of me,
I can put the
Scarecrow right here.
And as I move my
phone around, I can
change where I'm rendering the
Scarecrow in the virtual scene
to match my physical
environment.
So that allows you to
register virtual objects
to your physical scene in a
very natural and intuitive way.
The second capability
that ARCore provides
is something called
lighting estimation.
So here, continuing our
"Wizard of Oz" theme,
we've got the Cowardly Lion.
And when you turn
off the lights,
say we want to make the lion
afraid because it's cowardly.
So here, ARCore is
looking at the camera feed
and it is estimating
the real world
lighting of your environment.
And with that estimate,
ARCore can now
light characters in
a realistic fashion,
helping you to build a more
immersive experience that
looks natural because the
virtual objects that you're
putting in your
scene look correct.
So you can see the
tone on the lion change
when it goes from light to dark.
And you can even
script interactions
for your characters.
In this case, making the lion
afraid when the lights go off.
And the third capability
that ARCore provides
is environment understanding.
So here, as ARCore is
moving around the world
and it's tracking its
motion and it's also
estimating the lighting
of the environment,
ARCore is also trying
to recognize surfaces.
So ARCore might
recognize this plane
below me which is the
ground, or this surface here
which is the table,
or even maybe
this vertical surface behind me.
And it allows you
to place objects
that are grounded to reality.
So if we want to place
the Android character
on this table, I can
detect the surface
and actually place my virtual
character on a physical object
in the world.
So those are three
capabilities-- motion tracking,
lighting estimation, and
environment understanding.
And when you combine
them together,
it allows you to build
these experiences that
were previously
impossible, that bring
the virtual and
physical worlds together
and meld them into
a new reality that
enables people to see and
experience your application
in a new and different light.
And we're really excited
about this and the opportunity
to bring apps to our
ecosystem for it.
And so we have
worked really, really
hard to expose
support for ARCare
on as many devices as possible.
And with help from our partners
in our Android OEM ecosystem,
today ARCore is supported
on over 100 million devices.
And we're working to increase
that number every single day.
We believe that
augmented reality
is a next shift in computing,
and that soon everyone
will take for granted that
this power is in their devices.
So that's our scale.
But we're also
interested in scaling
the capabilities of ARCore.
We want to teach ARCore to do
new and interesting things.
And that's what the rest of
the talk is going to be about.
So today, we're announcing
some new things in ARCore.
And they fall broadly
into two categories.
The first is we're announcing
some new capabilities
for ARCore, improving
what these devices can do.
And those are Augmented
Images and Cloud Anchors.
And we'll talk about
them in the talk today.
And then we're also announcing
some new tools for ARCore.
One new tool is how you
can use augmented reality
on the web, which we
think is really exciting.
And you can check a talk to
that later today at 12:30 PM.
And another is how
you can more easily
write 3D applications for
Android and AR specifically.
We've introduced our
scene form library,
which is a helper library
for 3D rendering on Android.
And we encourage you to check
out that talk at 5:30 today.
So enough about the preamble.
We're now going to get
into the meat of it
and talk about
what's new in ARCore.
And I'm going to kick it off
with our first feature, which
are augmented images.
So augmented images
stem from your feedback.
We've heard you as you develop
augmented reality applications,
ask us, hey, AR is great.
Wouldn't it be better
if we could also
trigger augmented
reality experiences off
of 2D images in our
environment, like movie posters
or textbooks?
And so augmented images
seek to do just that.
Augmented images
provide a mechanism
to take a 2D
texture in the world
and make it more
engaging by expanding it
to a 3D interactive object.
And to show a concrete
example of this,
consider the case where we
have a new children's toy.
It's called Castle Toy, I think.
And we have told
ARCore, hey, we want
you to recognize the surface
of this Castle Toy box.
So now, as part of
the product, you
can hold up your phone to
it and you can actually
have an immersive
experience come out
of that box, a more engaging
experience for your product.
So augmented images allow you to
detect these kinds of textures.
And then script behaviors,
and take this 2D flat surface
and turn it into 3D, which
we think is really exciting.
And it's based on your feedback.
You told us that you wanted
this feature and now we have it.
So that's the future
in a nutshell.
But I want to tell
you about how it works
and also how you can use
it in your applications.
So augmented images
fundamentally
work in three major steps.
The first step is you
need to tell ARCore what
images you're interested in.
And there are two ways
that you can do this.
The first way to do
this is to tell ARCore
that you want to detect certain
kinds of images in real time.
So you could download
an image from a server.
You could have it bundled
in your application.
And you tell ARCore
at runtime that,
hey, please load
this image, learn
how to detect it in the scene,
and tell me when you do.
The second option is to
tell ARCore in advance.
So we've provided tools where
you, on your desktop computer,
can take up to 1,000 images
and train ARCore on them
in an offline fashion,
saying, I would
like you to be able to recognize
any of these 1,000 images
when I run my
application on device.
All right.
So the next step
is now that we've
trained ARCore to
recognize these images,
we actually want to
detect them on device.
We want to show ARCore a
scene and have it detect
the images that we've trained.
So now, when ARCore moves
around the environment
with your phone,
ARCore will also
look for textures
in the environment
and try to match those to the
textures that you trained on.
And when it finds
a match, ARCore
provides you information
on that match
with the third step, which is
it gives you a tracked object.
So for those of you who
are familiar with ARCore,
tracked objects are a notion
for the physical objects
in space that
ARCore knows about.
To this point,
that's been planes
like these surfaces, both
horizontal and now vertical.
But it also can give you points
in the environment of interest
that you can attach to.
And now, an augmented image is
just another tracked object.
So you use it just
like you would
use any plane or any point.
And you can attach
your virtual content
to the detection of the
physical object in the world.
So that's it.
Really simple,
three simple steps--
number one, tell ARCore
what you're looking for.
Number two, have ARCore
detect objects in the scene.
And number three, attach
your virtual content
to these physical objects.
And because this is a
developer conference,
I want to show you those
same steps in code.
We're going to go through
them in Java really quick.
But this is also the same
for Unity and Unreal.
The concepts apply across all
of our development environments.
So we'll go through the
same exact steps again.
Step number one is you need to
add images to ARCore's memory.
You need to tell it what
images it's interested in.
And so here, we're creating this
new augmented images database
and just adding an image to it.
And we're doing this in
real time on the phone.
Now, this is a
little bit expensive.
You have to pay a
cost, computationally,
for each image you add.
So a little bit later,
I'll also show you
how to create it with the
alternate flow on the computer.
But once ARCore has a database
of images that it can detect,
we go to the second step.
So the second step is
ARCore is always looking
for those images for you.
And you can get it from the
AR frame, each and every frame
that AR sees or that
ARCore sees in the world.
So now, you've got a list
of all the augmented images
in the scene.
And you want to attach
virtual content to it.
So that brings me
to the third step.
So for step number
three, you just
take the augmented images, the
augmented image that you want.
And you create an
anchor off of it.
And then you can attach
virtual content to that anchor.
And it's the same as you would
for any kind of plane detection
or point detection that you've
been used to in the past.
So that's it,
three simple steps.
And if you want to do
the pre-computation
on the computer,
this is what you run.
So there's a command
called build-db.
And you can pass up to 1,000
images into this command.
And it'll build an image
database in advance
that you can then load in
ARCore using this code.
So this loads the database
from file, pulls it in.
It's computationally efficient
because ARCore has already
done the work that it needs
to to be able to recognize
these images later.
And now, you can go off and
running with the same other two
steps that we showed before,
which is detecting the image
and then placing
content relative to it.
All right.
Pretty simple.
Now, I want to show you
a demo of this in action.
So we're going to switch
to the Pixel phone here.
And we're going to run
this augmented images demo.
So here, we've actually trained
ARCore to recognize this poster
on the wall.
And so when I look
at the poster,
you can see that it fades out
and it goes from 2D into 3D.
And now as I move, the
perspective that I see changes.
So I've got a 3D object
coming out of this 2D texture.
Nothing's really
changed in the world.
But I can make it more
engaging and immersive.
All right.
So that's the demo of augmented
images, pretty simple.
And now, I want to talk a
little bit about some use cases.
Posters are great
for demos, but we
think augmented images have
a lot more potential as well.
So the first use case that we're
excited about is education.
Imagine a textbook coming
to life in front of you,
or going into a museum tour
where artwork on the wall
jumps out at you and
gives you more information
about the artists or maybe
their progression as they
were sketching a painting.
We think augmented images
are useful for advertising.
Advertising is all
about engagement.
Imagine being at a movie
theater and holding your phone
up to a movie poster and
having content come out
or telling you showtimes.
Or imagine being at a bus
stop with a little bit of time
to kill and engaging
with the ad that you
have on the side of
the bus stop station.
We think augmented images can
also be useful for the products
that you're advertising.
So here, you can
build products that
meld the physical and
digital worlds, that
bring both together.
It could be Castle Toy, where
you have an experience that
comes out of the
box itself, or it
could be a how-to guide
for your coffee machine
as you try to make
coffee for the first time
with your expensive
espresso machine
and you have no idea what to do.
So we think augmented
images expand
the capabilities and
usefulness of AR in general.
And we're really,
really excited to see
what you build with them.
And we also are not done yet.
We're going to talk about
one more feature today.
And for that, I'm
going to bring out
James Birney, who's a product
manager who works with me.
And he's going to talk to
you about Cloud Anchors.
I think you'll really enjoy it.
Thanks very much.
Come on up, James.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES BIRNEY: So real
quick, before we get
started-- you guys have
been sitting for awhile.
And I really like doing this
at the beginning of our things.
We're going to do the wave real
quick going across the room.
All right?
You guys ready?
Laptops ready?
All right, three, two, one--
up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Yay, ARCore.
Woo-hoo!
It worked.
[LAUGHS]
All right.
Thank you, guys.
So like Eitan mentioned,
my name's James Birney.
I'm a product manager on
ARCore, and specifically
on Cloud Anchors.
Raise your hand if you saw
the Cloud Anchors announcement
yesterday.
All right, good.
That's slightly more
than half, awesome.
So that's what we're going
to cover in this section.
Hopefully you guys
are going to be
really excited by the time we
get through talking with Cloud
Anchors and you're going to want
to immediately start building.
So before we hop
into Cloud Anchors,
it's really important to
start with where AR is today.
So could I get a quick hand if
you've built an AR app before?
All right, so that's
roughly about half of you.
So for the other half,
what happens when--
let's say that
together we're going
to build an app where we're
going to place some dinosaurs.
And so we're going to
have a T-Rex over here
and maybe a
Triceratops over here.
And they're going to interact.
The way that we would do
that in the AR app today
is we would plant an anchor.
And then the T-Rex
and the Triceratops
would be placed as relative
offsets from those anchors.
And that becomes your
reference frame in your AR app.
Now, let's say that Eitan
were to come back up on stage.
He's not going to come up
because that's a long walk.
But Eitan goes ahead and creates
a separate dinosaur app over
here.
And he places, say, a
bunch of pterodactyls.
And again, he plants an anchor.
And his pterodactyls are all
placed relative to that anchor.
Now, what's missing
is Eitan's app
is running in a
different reality,
a different augmented
reality than the app
that we have over here.
And the reason why
is those two anchors
can't talk to each other.
So this is what
Cloud Anchors solves,
is we give you the ability
to create a shared reference
frame.
So that reference frame
I was mentioning before,
where you have the anchor
and you have the offsets
to our T-Rex and
to our pterodactyl,
that now, we can have a
common anchor in the middle
and all the AR content.
So everything from
pterodactyls to T-Rexes
are able to then
interact and play.
And then you can create these
really fun experiences where
not only is my
content interacting
with Eitan's content, but I
can control Eitan's content.
He can control mine.
That's pretty cool.
So that's kind of an abstract
thing where I'm literally
moving my hands around onstage.
A more concrete example
would be our Just a Line app,
which if you haven't
seen it before
is an experimental app
that we as Google built.
It literally draws a
single line in space.
And what we added
to it is the ability
to do not just one artist,
but multiple artists drawing
in the same space.
So I'm going to show
you an extended version
of the video they showed you
really quickly yesterday,
where you can see multiple
artists drawing together.
And hopefully you
see from this video
the powerful experience
that you get out
of this, where now, you're able
to interact with your friends
and draw together.
And when one person
draws a line,
you can build on top of that.
So I'll give it a second
here for the video to finish
and for you guys to
absorb what's going on
because that's a new concept.
OK, so let's talk a
little bit about how
we create these cloud anchors.
We've done an awful lot of
work to make it very simple.
So it's only a few steps.
Let me walk you through them.
So step one is--
let's say in this example,
we make our stick woman.
Her name is going to be Alice.
And Alice is going to
place a cloud anchor.
Now, the verb that we use
to create a cloud anchor
is called hosting.
The reason why is we're going
to host that native anchor up
to the cloud.
So when we host
that cloud anchor,
the features which
are the visual
features in the environment.
So let's say that
Alice is standing here.
And as Alice is
looking at the table,
she places a cloud
anchor or the app
will place a cloud anchor
for her on the stage, right
here next to our
beautiful succulent.
Do you guys like our succulent?
OK.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
I appreciate the one person.
OK.
So what the phone is going to
extract from the environment
is all the points
where these leaves come
to what the phone will see
as contrast points, where
the colors change, where
the lighting changes.
So the edge of this
table, the edge
of this tablecloth,
every point where
the leaves kind of change, those
are the visual features that
get abstracted and then
get uploaded to the cloud.
That then gets
saved and processed.
And what Alice gets
back in a couple
seconds is that cloud anchor.
Now, in that cloud anchor is
a really important attribute.
That attribute is
the Cloud Anchor ID.
So you can think about
the Cloud Anchor ID as--
you can think
about Cloud Anchors
the same way you
think about a file.
So say you're going to save
a file to Google Drive.
And when you save it, you need
to create a file name, right?
Well, with Cloud
Anchors, we're going
to create essentially that
file name or that ID for you.
And that ID is the
way that you're
going to reference it later.
Would be really hard to find the
file without knowing the name,
right?
So the Cloud Anchor ID
is the same concept.
So how this comes
into play is all
Alice needs to do to get Bob,
our stick man over there,
to connect to Alice's
cloud anchor is to--
excuse me-- is to send over
that Cloud Anchor ID to Bob.
And that's all she needs
to send over to Bob.
Once Bob has the
Cloud Anchor ID,
he then uses the
Cloud Anchor ID to--
and our verb here is resolve.
In resolving, we'll
add the Cloud Anchor ID
to Bob's reference frame.
So let's say that Bob is
standing right here as well.
He looks at the same area.
The visual features that will
get uploaded to the cloud,
in the cloud will match
those visual features
against the visual features that
Alice had previously uploaded.
And we will give Bob
back a cloud anchor
that will be relative
to where his device is.
So even though both devices
are in different locations,
we'll create the cloud anchor in
a consistent physical location.
And that's the magic.
Because they're in a
consistent physical location,
you then have a shared
reference frame.
And then at that
point, we can place--
again, let's use dinosaurs
because everybody
loves dinosaurs, right--
we can place our dinosaurs
relative to that cloud anchor
and we can start our
shared AR experience.
Hopefully that makes sense.
Oh, cloud anchor comes back.
And then I'm going to
tie it all together here.
We created a very
fancy visualization.
The orange dots
that come up, those
are the visual features
we were talking about.
They go up to the cloud.
Bob uploads his visual
features up to the cloud.
They get matched.
And then the two of them create
the same shared reference
frame.
And then once that shared
reference frame is created--
wait a second for the
GIF to loop around--
you'll see that
spaceship show up.
And then the two of them
can follow the spaceship
around the room.
And once they're
paired, then the devices
can go anywhere in the room.
And they're in the
same reference frame.
And they can interact together.
All right.
So let's keep on going one
level deeper, like "Inception,"
with some sample code.
OK, so same format as
before, but before we
get to those two methods
of hosting and resolving,
it's really important that
we enable the feature.
So when you're
working with ARCore,
interact with the session.config
and turn on our feature.
You need to do this
on all devices.
But hopefully this is
pretty straightforward.
Then on the first device--
so this is Alice's
device, the one
that creates the Cloud Anchor.
The main method we need to
call here is HostCloudAnchor.
On HostCloud-- and then with--
excuse me.
With HostCloudAnchor,
you can feed
in any preexisting
native anchor.
So as Eitan was
mentioning before,
normally this is created from
a horizontal plane or now
from a vertical plane.
And you can pass in that
anchor into HostCloudAnchor.
Asynchronously that
call will complete
in a couple of seconds.
And what comes back
is your cloud anchor.
Now, what did we talk about is
the really important thing that
comes from the cloud anchor?
All right, Cloud Anchor ID.
Thank you.
[LAUGHS] So then,
it is completely up
to you what means of
device-to-device communication
you want to use.
The demo that we're going
to show you in a second
uses Firebase.
There's also two other
demos in the Sandboxes
I'd encourage you to check out.
Those also use Firebase as well.
It's a great means to
communicate between.
But you can use
any means you want.
So then on Bob's device--
and it's a really
important point here.
This is not limited to just Bob.
We could also have Bob,
Jerry, Johnny, Eitan.
And it can be as many
users as we want.
That all they need to do to
join that cloud anchor is
receive the Cloud Anchor ID.
That's the one that
Alice just sent over.
And then we need to
resolve that cloud anchor.
In order to resolve the cloud
anchor, it's dead simple.
All you need to do is pass
in the Cloud Anchor ID.
In the background,
under the hood,
we will take those
visual features
from what the user is
currently looking at.
So it's important that the user
is, again, currently looking
where Alice was.
And we'll upload those
features and then give you
that cloud anchor back.
And then at that point,
you're good to go.
You can start placing assets
relative to that cloud anchor.
So quick question,
what operating system
were those devices in that
code example running on?
Anyone?
All right.
So the really
important point here
is Cloud Anchors work
on both Android--
which means any ARCore-enabled
Android device--
and any iOS ARKit-enabled
device, which for today
is going to be iPhones.
And we believe this is
incredibly important to making
shared AR a reality.
There's no reason that
we should discriminate
which of our friends
can play a game with us
based on which operating
system they run on their phone.
That's not really
important to whether or not
Eitan and I are friends.
If he has an
iPhone, he should be
able to play shared
AR with me, right?
So now, I'm going to invite
Eitan on up on stage.
And we're going to give
you guys a live demo.
Because it's one thing
to say that everything
works cross-platform,
but it's another thing
to show you guys
with a live demo.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
All right.
So maybe one last poll
just to get started.
Who thinks I'm going
to win this game?
Raise your hand.
Oh.
Oh, it's tough.
All right, who thinks
James is going to win?
That's the rest of you, right?
[LAUGHS]
JAMES BIRNEY: So you guys
are getting to know Eitan
better every minute.
And it's really important to
know Eitan sandbags a lot.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: OK.
I just got to join this room.
OK.
So now, I'm going
to set up my board.
And James, you set up yours.
JAMES BIRNEY: Yeah.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: And you
want to get close to me, right?
JAMES BIRNEY: [LAUGHS]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
You need that help.
JAMES BIRNEY: I'm also
showing off a little bit here.
You can see as
mine's moving around,
the same state is
being reflected in both
at the same physical location.
So I'm going to press that.
Here's our futuristic-looking
light boards.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
All right, here we go.
JAMES BIRNEY: And we have
people in the back that
are organizing bets,
in case anybody wants
to make money off of this.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah.
So the goal here is to turn
the other person's board
your color.
And I feel like James
has been sandbagging me
in all of our practice sessions
because he's doing much
better than he has in the past.
Let's see.
JAMES BIRNEY: Oh, no.
That was [INAUDIBLE].
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Oh, so close.
Hold on.
All right.
Just one more shot,
one more shot.
JAMES BIRNEY: You'll notice
that Eitan and I both can't
multitask--
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Oh, no.
JAMES BIRNEY: --very well.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Did I get him?
JAMES BIRNEY: Oh.
All right.
Thank you.
Hey, it worked.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
And just to reiterate,
so that was an iPhone
that Eitan was using.
This is a Pixel 2.
But this very well could
have been any Android
ARCore-enabled device.
That could have been any
ARKit-enabled device.
And there's my clicker.
OK, so let's talk
about use cases.
That was gaming.
That was an example of
gaming working really well.
But shared AR does not
need to stop at gaming.
We think there's a whole
lot of other categories
where shared AR can make a
big difference in the world.
Oops.
Lance, help me.
Can you go back a slide, please?
Pretty please?
Thank you.
OK, so four categories that
briefly let's talk about.
So one is in the
education space.
This is an example of--
let me phrase this as
a question instead.
Raise your hand after
I say two options.
Option A, you can
learn about what
it's like to explore on
Mars and the Mars missions
from a textbook,
option A. Option B,
you can learn from
an interactive 3D
model of the Rover that you can
play with with your friends.
All for option A?
OK.
Option B?
All right.
See, we're making improvements
in how people learn.
And the demo that
we're showing you here,
this is an example
that NASA built for us.
This doesn't need to stop
at space exploration,
although that's a pretty
big area to explore.
You could do this
as well in any sort
of visual area such as biology.
There's a couple cool
demos where you can explore
the human body together.
And I'll leave it at that.
Let's hop on down to
creative expression.
So you saw our Just
a Line example,
which is where we draw
the white line in space.
But we can go beyond that.
Take for example
this block building
app that was built
by [INAUDIBLE],, where
you can build a full
block building thing
and then 3D print it later.
It's very, very cool.
And you can imagine what
this would look like
as well with the AR Stickers.
Raise your hand if you
played with AR Stickers.
So you can imagine what
this would look like if now
as you're placing
Stormtroopers or--
help me, the Demogorgon--
as you're placing Demogorgon,
someone else can place El
and have the fight be between
your different phones.
That would be a
very fun experience.
Gaming-- so now, you can do
ice fishing with your friends.
Haven't you guys always
wanted to do that?
[LAUGHING] Believe
me, it actually
is an awful lot more fun than
it sounds when you just say
ice fishing with your friends.
It's particularly fun on
a hot day in San Francisco
to be able to look
down at the sidewalk
and turn the sidewalk
into a ice fishing pool.
Beyond ice fishing, you can
imagine playing laser tag
with your friends.
Can now be just
with your phones.
You don't need to
buy special gear.
You can just-- two
people, quickly pair,
do host and resolve.
And then you're off and
going, and playing laser tag
with as many of your
friends as possible
because Cloud Anchors are not
limited just to two devices.
You can use n number of devices.
And then shopping--
so how many of you
guys have bought something and
then had your partner, when
it actually showed up, veto it?
Then you had to return it.
Show of hands.
Yeah, that's a big pain, right?
Then you have to go through find
the UPS store, the FedEx store,
mail it back.
That's not a good experience.
It's a lot better if you can
preview it with your partners.
So now, with Cloud Anchors, if
I'm placing a speaker system
here, I can have my wife also
look at that speaker system
from her phone.
And there's a feeling of
consistency and a feeling
of trust that you built
if you're the advertiser
or the e-commerce site--
that if you have two
users looking at it
and it shows up consistently
for both of them,
you build this trust that
the product I'm buying,
when I'm previewing
it, is actually
going to look that
way when it shows up.
Because it's showing
up on multiple devices.
All right.
So that's everything
for Cloud Anchors.
Now, let's talk about
getting started.
So ARCore, no surprise, already
supports Unity and Unreal,
your standard game engines.
And then obviously we
support Android Studio
for Android Native Development.
As well, since Cloud
Anchors are cross-platform,
we provide a SDK so that
you can do your development
Xcode as well.
All four of these environments
are live as of yesterday
at 1:00 PM.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So for the folks
here at I/O, you guys
have a bunch of
resources-- or you folks
have a bunch of resources that
you have at your disposal.
Please take advantage of them.
There are three awesome
demos in the Sandbox.
If you guys liked
playing Light Board,
and especially if you want
to play Eitan in Light Board,
our Sandbox is right over
there in the AR Sandbox.
Eitan will be there up
until somebody beats him.
Right, Eitan?
Yeah, thank you.
We also have the Just a Line
demo over in the Experiments
Sandbox.
Please check that out.
And then the demo that Eitan
showed with this picture
frame as well as two others are
available in the AR Sandbox.
It's a really,
really fun exhibit.
Please go ahead and
play around with it.
I suspect it'll give you a bunch
of very cool ideas for what
you can build.
For Codelabs, we have over
80 workstations set up.
Please play around with them.
Every workstation is also
paired with an Android device.
So not only can you
go through the code,
but you can actually
compile it onto the phone.
And then you can see what the
code you just built actually
works like on a phone.
And then we also
have office hours.
Please take advantage of that.
We have some incredibly
intelligent guru staff
to answer any
questions you have.
And then a quick shameless plug.
Our team, the ARCore
team is incredibly busy
giving talks this week.
Please take advantage of those.
Done an awful lot of work
putting those in to you
to give you a very
concise explanation.
There's two more today
and two more tomorrow.
And then after I/O or
for the folks online,
developers.google.com/ar
has all the extra resources,
plus all the Codelabs are
also available on there.
And again, all four of our SDKs
are available as of yesterday.
So thank you very much.
Appreciate your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]